موجه عالميه جديده من الانبهار بمصر من
الاثار الى صور الفضائيه فما القصه
[موسيقى]
رائد الفضاء الياباني وكوتشي وكاتا تغزل
بجمال عاصمه المصريه القاهره في تغريده له
عبر منصه تويتر والتقط صورا لها من الفضاء
قائلا بدات القاهره مشرقه حقا واضواءها
ساطعه في وسط ظلمه الفضاء الخارجي
[موسيقى]
الفضاء يكشف عن اولي صوره للقاهره من
الفضاء ويؤكد مدينه ساطعه وسط الظلام واخر
ينشر مجرى اعظم الانهار بالعالم وتغريده
ناريه لا لهم ماسك عن الحضاره القديمه كل
ذلك يحصل في وقت متزامن
[موسيقى]
عدد من رواد الفضاء سبق ان شاركوا ايضا
صور للقاهره والنيل بمصر التقتها من
علامات محطه الفضاء الدوليه مثل رائد
الفضاء الفرنسي توماس صوره فضائيه على
حسابي في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تظهر
دلتا بشكل مذهل وجميل واثار اعجاب
الكثيرين وكتب على حسابه في موقع فيسبوك
يحتضن وادي نهر النيل العديد من المدن
وعلى اضواءها يبدو احد اعظم الانهار في
العالم لغايه الروعه والجمال
واثاره تغريده رجل الاعمال الامريكي الى
المقطع عن الحضاره المصريه القديمه ردود
افعال واسعه نطاق من المشاهير والنجوم في
مصر وشارك ماسك مقطع فيديو لمعبد دندره
المصري الواقع بمحافظه قنا في صعيد مصر
وعلق قائلا مصر القديمه كانت متوهجه
[موسيقى]
اكثر من سبعه ملايين مشاهده